uh now to a story affecting every
american the rising cost of groceries
fruit and vegetable prices went up 5
in 2021 according to government figures
now orange juice may soon be in the
shorter supply making breakfast more
expensive as well manuel bajorquez is in
florida with more on this story
tarika good morning florida officials
say this fruit represents a 6.7 billion
dollar industry in the state that
supports more than thirty thousand jobs
according to the latest figures but in
citrus groves like this one an invasive
insect is spreading a disease called
citrus greening to once healthy trees
and that's taking a bite out of the crop
see all that that's all next year's crop
right there at one of his groves outside
orlando brian farina showed us what a
healthy orange tree looks like that's
what you want yep so this is what we
want and what a tree plagued by citrus
greening looks like so it kills it from
the inside yeah all the roots are going
to go first wow so when you have no
roots you have no leaves no fruit
some trees don't die but produce oranges
that are smaller green and have less
sugar not as sweet harder to sell and
bad for business there is no known cure
for citrus greening in fact in groves
like this one it's safe to assume most
trees have some degree of it one
telltale sign the amount of fruit that's
fallen to the ground or is unusually
small
here's how hard florida's orange crop is
getting squeezed at its peak the state
produced more than 244 million boxes of
oranges a year
this year it's forecast to produce only
44.5 million prices for orange juice
concentrate rose nearly 14 percent in
the last year amid strong demand during
the coronavirus pandemic and the low
crop yield will likely drive prices even
higher in 2022
about 93 percent of the crop goes into
juice processing we've seen strong
stable demand for florida orange juice
but we don't quite have the production
that we had before the disease is
threatening family farms like farinas
his grandparents started it 70 years ago
when they first put down roots in lake
county florida
this is what you devote your life to yep
yeah all of our land is citrus and so
when you hear numbers like that it is
devastating
florida's fruit and vegetable
association says over much of the past
two decades the number of acres
harvested for oranges in florida has
dropped by more than half as some
farmers look for other work or sell
their land to developers brian farina
for one says he does not plan to sell
his land but he has diversified what he
grows tony
manuel bajorka is in umatilla florida
they call it nature's hometown
explaining why the price of orange juice
keeps going up manny thank you very much